a very special woman making a difference
here in our community being honored once
again
you may remember her we first profiled
carolyn muscari when she was awarded
advocate of the year by the national
casa association she's been a volunteer
with casa for 40 years giving foster
children a voice in court yesterday the
county recognized all of her hard work
for children who were abused and
neglected
i became a casa because i believe that
people are the only important thing in
the world and children are the most
vulnerable
and if they have somebody that cares
about them it could very well prevent
them from taking the wrong path
she says she has no plans to stop
serving here locally boy are we lucky to
have her here in our community i think
about that for four decades and
navigating the court system the juvenile
court system i mean that is a
challenging challenging position to be
in and for her and her team to help
people navigate that all is just so
commendable how many kids i was just
wondering
so many yeah i read more than 150 but
i'm not sure if that's right it makes
sense well and joe just did a profile
joe moeller did a profile on carolyn a
little while ago as well to talk about
all the work she's done in the valley so
good stuff